hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game this one from the Julius
bar generation cup the winner section it
is
those of you who remember uh and I
imagine most of you do another couple
Saturday was the 2021 World rapid
champion and this is the rapid time
format so uh you know he he definitely
knows his way around the chessboard
there uh but the problem is he already
lost two games so this is the third game
and he absolutely must uh strike back so
let's check it out and see what happened
here another big has the white pieces
and he opens with Pawn to D4 we have
Knight to F6 uh C for E6 and now Knight
to F3 uh we have Pawn to D5 the Queen's
Gambit declined is on the board and now
Knight to C3 we have the three Knights
of the Queen's Gambit declined and now
C5 the semi tarash is on the board and
this is uh very very uh tactical stuff
now see captures on D5 is the movie
everyone plays here sometimes E3 is
played and very very rarely blush up to
G5 but zika after sun D5 is pretty much
automatic and top level we have C
captures on V4 now interestingly here
there are only three possible moves
there's e captures on the five Knight
captures on D5 and C captures on D4 any
other move for black loses the game
terribly even if you tried making a move
here for black other than these three
moves you just get absolutely destroyed
it's a you know true story so see
captures on D4 this is the sharpest line
uh not the most popular one but
definitely the sharpest one and now
Knight captures on D4 we have Knight
captures on D5 and Bishop to D2 so you
are ready to strike in the center with
E4 Bishop to C5 not challenging the
Knight not allowing the free for move
and Knight to B3 attacks the bishop
Bishop to E7 and now Pawn to G3 first
getting ready to finger to the light
Square bishop and Castle kingside
um sorry not Bishop to B6 that was a
different game Bishop to E7 and now Pawn
to G3 and here we have castles and this
is a new move uh usually B6 is played
and sometimes Bishop TFC was played by
castles is a new move so now already as
of move 9 we have a completely new game
and it will seemingly give black
problems with the development of the
queen side as another back will show
Bishop to G2 we have Knights the B6 now
bringing the Knight back and now Knights
the A5 now how is the latest at the
defended the B7 Pawn well that's exactly
the point you don't have to do it Bishop
to B4 or I mean you have to do it but
you you have to do it wisely and here oh
it is a defensive with a tactic now if
you capture on B7 regardless of what
width you could capture with the bishop
let's say you capture with the bishop
the problem is you just capture the
bishop and after Knight captures Queen
E7 traps the Knight the bishop here
takes away all of the squares the queen
also helps so you just blunder a piece
and it's not much better capturing with
the Knight if you capture with the
Knight Queen to E7 right away and how
are you uh the Savior Knight there's no
way to do it you will have to give up
two pieces for The Rook you're gonna
have to go Knight F5 after Bishop
captures okay you're gonna win the Rook
but then Knight captures bishop and
again black is much better here so
that's why after this um uh castles uh
and the Bishop B sorry and the bishop to
B4 move uh right my bad after this G3
and uh
Bishop the B4 move wow sorry uh Knight
the E4 was played uh so of course you
want to trade off uh the Bishops here
now comes Bishop captures an A5 Bishop
captures and now Knight the C6 going
after the bishop on A5 Bishop to C3 and
now Knight to D5 uh putting pressure on
the bishop so all it is that wants to
get rid of another mix Bishop pair as
well we have castles and pawn to B6 now
yes it opens up this diagonal but there
are three knights in between the bishop
and Rook so it's safe to do it we have
Queen to A4 putting pressure on the
Knight but just Bishop to B7 we have
Queen to A3 similar maneuver like Bobby
Fischer did against the Boris paski in
their wheelchair championship match and
now on to A5 uh Knight to D6 goes after
the bishop here and just the bishop to
A6 putting pressure on the E2 Pawn but
now comes the bishop captures on d5e
captures and Rook after D1 another big
says all right you capture on E2 I'm
gonna capture on D5 while it is
assistant nope that's not gonna happen
so Knight E7 he defends and now onto E4
so took not Rebecca a while to get that
E4 move in but the latest just continues
development Queen D7 he connects the
Rooks and now he of course wants to get
the Rook behind the Knight and put
pressure on that Knight and the problem
is if you go he captures on D5 yes you
win upon temporarily but then Rook after
d8 you have to move the Knight and then
of course the Knight Will capture back
on on D5 so after Queen to D7 uh we have
Bishop to D4 uh here another way puts
pressure on the B6 pawn and now look at
this D captures on e4 Knight captures on
e4 and now Rook after d8 so it seems
like you could capture on B6 attack the
rook and the queen but of course alireza
would very happily give up the queen
here because once the king moves uh
there's really nothing to do Bishop to
F1 check is coming now if you go down
the board then this is just a nice
trackmate and of course if you go up the
board then Rook to D3 check wins back
the queen and you are up a lot of
material so instead after Rook f38 we
have Queen to F3 and now we have Queen
to C6 countering the the White Queen we
have Rook 8 to C1 and they are going for
a free Tempo here Queen to G6 and now
Pawn to H4 and now it is I could play
Pawn to H5 but I think he wanted to
avoid Knight to G5 so he played Pawn to
H6 uh we have Ponte H5 and now Queen
back to E6 so really harassing all it is
is Queen there Rook to E1 and now Queen
to F5 finally all it is a manages to
trade off Queens Queen captures Knight
captures and now finally Bishop captures
on B6 so another Baker grabs that pawn
and what does alireza get for it he
played The Rook D to B8 and okay Bishop
captures an A5 wins another Pawn other
as a wins back one Pawn Rook capture
some B2 and now the position is a really
tricky one it seems like uh with all
this um uh you know uh variations
anotherbeck was able to win a pawn and
but now his spawn on A2 is hanging and
there's just no good way to defend it
and you should just ignore that the
problem is your bishop and A5 isn't
defendant it's merely in the way of of
this bishop should this be should move
somehow with Tempo you would lose
material but uh here another way played
Rook to A1 he wanted to defend his A2
pawn and by doing so he lost the game
it's not an easy move to spot it there
is only one move that wins the game for
alireza and he found it now let's see if
you can find it feel free to pause the
video and win the game for alireza while
I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always looking
for tricky Night Moves as Knights
definitely are tricky bastards and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is Knight to D4 this is the move
and there is no defense um against all
of the tricky Knight jumps Knight to F3
will Fork the king and the Rook If you
defend against that Knights the C2 will
Fork the two Rooks and it seems like
there's really nothing you can do here
like even if you play something like
Rook e to D1 okay you avoid the king
fork and The Rook Fork but you run into
night the E2 checking HD and now Bishop
to B7 and like we said the Knight is now
attacked the bishop is attacked there's
no way to avoid losing a piece so what
Nollywood did here is the only thing he
could he played Rook e to B1 he says all
right and now your Rook is hanging so
you don't have time for any tricky jumps
but alireza says Rook captures on B1
check Rook captures on B1 and now Bishop
to D3 attacking The Rook attacking the
Knight and attacking the bishop here and
again doesn't seem like it works because
Northern finds Rock of the D1 of the
bishop and the Knight are attacked here
but here comes Knight to F3 with Chuck
and he was in this position on a move 35
that Notre cabosator resigned to the
game and with it the match he lost three
to zero as did most of the other players
as you'll see later on when we check out
the standings so here you resign because
okay you can play King G2 attack the
Knight but once Bishop captures
um on e4 uh you cannot capture on F3
also very nasty discoveries are coming
so he will know the record will just be
down a full piece so of course you
cannot do that let me just load the
standings from the uh sorry not that uh
where do I have the standings I'm pretty
sure I had him somewhere
nope
just so you see uh the the other ones uh
let me just see if I have it here no
yeah okay I don't have it so I'm just
gonna tell you what happened uh sorry
about that
in the other matches
uh that's yeah there we go
with a result of three to zero Wesley so
also defeated pavelanov with a score of
three to zero Fabiano caruana had a had
a pretty tough match it went all the all
the way to Armageddon he was able to
beat Dennis lazavik and the Magnus
Carlsen was able to beat amitabatabai uh
the first game was drawn in the two
other games were won by Magnus Carlsen
so next alireza will face Wesley so in
the semi-finals um uh so we're gonna
check that out as well if you have any
other favorite games do use hashtag
suggestion as uh even if I don't show
your game right away sometimes when I
don't have anything planned or if there
is not an active event going on in the
world I will go over your suggestions uh
but I always use the use the filter
hashtag suggestion when I uh browse the
my emails or or comments on YouTube so
if you haven't used hashtag suggestion
chances are I'm gonna miss your
suggestion for the game and also uh for
those who don't have Twitter I actually
uh met uh met up with alireza he was
visiting Croatia he was in Zagreb so we
met for now for a meal uh they have a
very nice photo of alireza and myself uh
yeah we had a meal we we talked for
about an hour and a half maybe even two
hours it was a very very enjoyable
experience he's uh quite the gentleman
and you know we covered uh you know a
huge array of different topics not just
chess and yeah if any of you guys were
interested yeah he's uh he's a a a a a
very fine gentleman uh so yeah that's
the game hope you guys enjoyed it I
would like to thank Andrew Wally
grossney chess festival.org.gg uh India
moon is the India is the best and crazy
day for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing uh to check
up on you wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day